play with a bag that you can afford to
go to zero because when you can afford
to go to zero
you're in it for the education not
stressing that you have to make a flip
because that [ __ ] everyone up
you've got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
hey what's up gary
i'm well brother good to see you
you too man you too thanks a lot yeah i
know uh you mentioned in the crypto
striker's discord maybe you wanted to
talk a little bit about strikers so i'm
sure there's a lot of people from the
community here but uh i'm super down to
just chat about it real quick and yeah i
love soccer so you know me it's like the
perfect project when i found it i was
like so psyched
i love that yeah i'm i'm just doing q
and a brother i don't necessarily have
any questions i've spent [ __ ] 150
hours studying
so no no and then in that case i got a
question for you so
um like with crypto strikers like
obviously there's not that much supply
of it right now people are still you
know rapping and having more supply like
do you think that like for you it's
obviously a long term play and
everything um but is there any type of
crypto strikers
how do you decide what you're buying
over there because like i know that you
know a lot about sports but are you do
you have any little thesis that may be
up your sleeve that you think people are
overlooking on crypto strikers or in
general when you look at a project
in general i always look at math and i
always make subjective calls on art
right
or culture and so it's always a mix i
think some people go too far in one
direction or the other right like oh
this says bubble gum but 80 have bubble
gum and
then that's maybe not as good in this
situation so i do a lot of math and art
analyzation i think with things like
sports you can't really
play the same way you play crypto punks
or things
where their subjectivity like mumbai is
gonna be better
than
uh eriksen and messi's gonna be better
than you know chico hernandez but like
but there's still going to be people
that are going to be interested in it i
think a lot of people are making a big
to-do that a lot of the tokens haven't
hit the open c yet my favorite thing
about
the blockchain is i know there's
slightly over 10 000 tokens
i know that there's you know two you
know
13 messy iconics or whatever the number
is like like the math is there
and so i think i i do think people fomo
into products too much in projects
like
you know i think um
i think people have to be thoughtful
about that but i'm incredibly interested
and i've been saying this over and over
and i'm sure a lot of you have seen this
and feel free to say i've seen it or had
not heard on the screen like
i believe that we're now in the summer
of projects like there are way too many
projects coming out every day
and so while this is happening while i
still want to get my fix as a collector
and as a learner
i'm spending more time looking back at
2017 18 and 19
and finding og projects a because i like
learning
and i like history b
as somebody who'd prefer not to lose
money i've worked [ __ ] 30 years super
hard for the money i have no matter how
much of it i have
you know i'm not in the business of
losing it and i think it's much more
interesting to
you know bet on some og [ __ ]
than it is on the stuff that's coming
out every day right now i'm incredibly
concerned about the projects that are
coming out every day right now even the
ones that are
so trash yeah it's about trash it's just
it's just human behavior right it's
supply and demand the community is gonna
keep growing but everybody here if this
is the first time you've been at the
forefront of one of these big moments
this is gonna take a long time
this is not like september 19th
everybody you know is gonna be buying
nfts this is like
this phase is going to take like two
three years
and so
if there's 50 [ __ ] projects coming
out every day
and we're three years away from like the
scale that everybody feels will be here
tomorrow
what do you think is going to happen
these same 50 000 people are only going
to have so much time and a lot of the
money that's running around is because
people made a lot of money in the short
term on crypto punch or bitcoin or
ethereum that's going to dry up
so
you know i'm incredibly
concerned about the projects
i think that you know i do think
there'll be five projects from the v
friends board ape cool cats you know
like that crew like i i do believe
there'll be three to five projects that
do really well from a investment
standpoint
i i do think
that most people are in it right now
financially and looking at these as
investments and as that goes i think 98
of things are
concerning and i think
you know
i see uh i see somebody mention jason
buy projects with a narrative
i i for one don't give a [ __ ] about the
white papers or the road maps they mean
nothing to me i've been investing my
whole life
people show me their road maps and their
investments all the time i don't care
what your [ __ ] plan is can you
[ __ ] execute it
it's very nice that you're telling me
what you're gonna do
everybody every company i've ever
invested in told me they were gonna make
me rich and it was gonna crush and be
the biggest company in the world and oh
by the way 98 of them have gone out of
business
there's gonna be an enormous amount of
carnage
with investing in the projects that are
out
just because the project's old doesn't
mean it's good either just because i'm
looking at 17 18 19 that doesn't mean
it's good either
but daniel what got me to the excitement
level i did
of the two projects i've been most
excited about you know there's three
projects i've been excited about over
the last six to eight weeks for real for
real outside of like dabbling world of
women
on a pure
i like the team
that's my intuition i like the art
that's my intuition i like the community
that's my intuition and i like the way
it looks and i feel people can associate
with it that's my intuition it's four
guesses
number two tom sacks rocket factory tom
sacks is one of the most
successful contemporary artists
in the world
he also put together maybe the best
project in my subjective opinion
besides be friends
with doing real life stuff put three
pieces together make a rocket we're
gonna film the shooting of the rocket
the rocket's gonna come down i'm gonna
put in a glass case and send it to you
oh by the way tom sacks his art in a
physical form normally is valued at like
30 to 60 thousand dollars on the low end
and i get a token and that
wild so to me that was brilliant and i
know he's running it and in it and in it
for life
and then number three was this crypto
strikers why why
it's very personal you know one of my
favorite sets of all time is
something called burke ross it's a
sports card from the 50s an entrepreneur
in a wild wild west east coast brooklyn
style just made baseball cards without
the rights from the league and the
players and you just put them out in his
cookies
that's a crazy story let me see let me
see if i can
put this in for you guys it's a wild
story
um
it's super rare found it it's super like
you know kind of like pirate you know
like
and
and crypto strikers you know
kind of represents to me the early
sense of you know ethereum projects it
was early 2018 made for an iconic moment
of the world cup
to your point and mine like it's got
some of the greatest footballers of all
time in the modern era in the set
you know
kevin de bruyne and like like and and
yeah
i think is still under underrated in
there i agree
so i i know enough about proper football
to be dangerous
um
and so
the other thing i'm looking for is i'm
i'm enjoying this era i'm trying to
figure out
what's going to be everyone's rookie nft
so i come from sports card world i
believe from 2017 to 2022 there will be
the establishment in a five-year window
that will be trading in 90 years from
now
on everyone's rookie nft
and i've and i believe crypto strikers
could be messi's
and ronaldo's and moon
excuse me um rookie rookie
nft and if that's right brother
and by the way
the other thing i like about it is it
looks like booms
which is my favorite subset in sports
cards from the art standpoint
it
it's so there's just a lot about it i
like
and
and it's also the most
popular global sport in the world and
blockchain is global
you know so
there's a lot that i like about it
awesome thanks gary no appreciate you uh
bringing me on the call i'll let someone
else uh get a question appreciate you
guys thank you
see you guys
next up is a board becky
i'm going to call it
not mbappe
if you guys don't like becky
hi can you see me this is crazy
i don't know if i can see yet usually it
populates the front screen
keep talking
hi gary this was really exciting um
i'm definitely not prepared for video
here no worries yeah my boyfriend in the
background is like is that gary
vaynerchuk yes it is
so anyways yeah i'm bored becky i'm
involved with the same lady squad
takeover
um we're really focused on
sort of fostering the community that we
have right now and and i don't want to
plug that by any means but i know but
it's becky it's one of the most
important things going on right we have
this
you know this misrepresent we have this
project
that i incredibly you know jumped on
immediately because i was it was it's
very important it continues to be very
important for me to see
all kinds of representation
in nft land
it's only good for the space it's only
good for society
i like the art it came out i got excited
right i didn't do as much homework you
know which is why i did so much homework
on this crypto strikers and like found
the founder and like you know you go
through it
ends up that it's misrepresentation
everyone you know obviously collapses
you and many others in the community
come in to save it fix it make it better
luckily there was some humanity on the
founders side on the other side they
hand over the project
right to in essence that eventually ends
up in your hand
and it's kind of cool it's like a real
fun thing to watch to see if
something can be resurrected
you know i always believe turning
something bad into something good
yeah
yeah i think that's that's our focus
right now i mean i have some logistical
questions that might not be appropriate
for this format but um maybe for more of
a macro level
what do you think would be the most
important thing for a group like us to
be thinking about as we we look to
rebuild this and and and really look to
focus on something that could be
sustainable
i think that part that second part was
the best part you need to do two things
it's like non-profits i'm on a lot of
boards i'm involved with a lot of stuff
and i always tell them
just because you're a non-profit doesn't
mean people should give you money
right like there's audacity and
expectation there's a lot of things
people can do and just because
this is being resurrected from a bad
situation doesn't mean everyone should
care or anything like that right
the reality is this project
has a great springboard now with your
energy and the rest of the community
but it's going to come down to what you
can do with it
yeah right like you know it's got this
kind of moment in time
you know and you're gonna have people on
both sides of the aisles like [ __ ] and
you might be rebranding it i've seen
some of your dms right [ __ ] that project
or let's all support this project but in
12 months in 24 months it's going to
come down to how good you are
so when you're thinking about that i
mean i've been really lucky because i
sort of
stumbled upon a few a couple of really
great partners with skill sets that are
way beyond my skill sets in this space
anyhow
um
how would you if you remain be thinking
about
finding the right people to bring in or
turn this over to or whatever that might
mean um especially in a space where we
don't really all know one another and
we're all entering it with kind of
it's all exploratory even for people
that are much more on the tech side than
i am like how do we find the right
people and figure out who we can trust
and by that i mean more like trust trust
their capacity and their skills
well you don't when you're guessing when
you're hiring you're guessing
yeah i mean you're now asking how to run
a business
[Music]
well i mean
this has been a crazy week i'll just put
that out there
and it's amazing i think i think look
i'll try to help as much as i can but
you can tell i'm a little bit underwater
and i'll poke in and out but rely on
people you trust people what you know
um it's imperative that you um
that you find people that have done it
before
right and then you gotta ask yourself
what you're trying to do like for
example it's very people like get like
the biggest confusion with b friends is
people think it's about v con
yeah
right like
me con is like an added value little
cherry on top
people ask me what am i doing with v
friends um i say i'm doing what noah
maxwell has on his back
drop right now i'm building intellectual
property that people are going to give a
[ __ ] about pokemon came out as a [ __ ]
you know card game and a game boy video
game and
you know 25 30 years later people want
to do a million different things with it
whether it's buy toys play the app
find virtual pokuchus in the ar world
like you know buy video games watch
movies
i'm going to develop the characters
yeah
what you know what are people going to
do
i think that most almost every
project that has come out this summer
is in the intellectual property game
yeah that's why i know 99 are going to
fail
yeah that's well that's one of our big
question marks on the logistic sides
about ip and what ip we own and how we
can use it moving forward and that's why
we've been having a conversation that
makes sense you have to definitely get
like if you don't own that you're not
building a business yeah yeah well you
know um gary i i really appreciate the
time i know those are the people here i
just want to say the only reason i'm
here at all is because i listened to you
and bought my first nfp and bought i
have four v friends so i'm rooting for
you you guys and your discord is my home
so i really appreciate it i really
appreciate everyone
thank you so much all right let's keep
it going mate
hayden
hey gary hey
all right so i was involved in top shot
a little while ago and i was in the
sneaker reselling so nfts i guess kind
of came natural with all this just
so
um my thing is i'm fairly new and i'm
just looking to see where i can find the
best projects like where
where to look to find like you know good
projects
i think i think twitter and discord like
live in it and think back to when you
started the sneaker flipping game there
was a day one
where you went somewhere to like read
top 10 list of the hottest sneakers
coming out right yeah this is different
because it's so wild wild west that it's
new and nobody really knows i didn't
think those little [ __ ] penguins were
gonna explode this week
you know like like you don't know you
don't know
and so what you need to do is a
and this will make sense to you play
with a bag that you can afford to lose
you got to start there is it a dollar is
it a million dollars play with a bag
that you can afford to go to zero
because when you can afford to go to
zero you're in it for the education
not stressing that you have to make a
flip because that [ __ ] everyone up my
friends everybody's in here you can't
play in nfts with money that you can't
afford to lose if you're even even if
you're [ __ ] sitting with a bee
friends bag that's monstrous and like i
could die tomorrow
now that might make them go up i don't
know how [ __ ] works but
i could
so then what
right like like you can't play
with
a bag that in nft that you can afford to
lose so first rule number one you have
to have to have to play with money you
can afford to lose and back and if this
hit for you and you've got four b
friends and sell one make all your
profits back and then play like even
though i believe in it the most on
anything on earth you know so there's
that yeah
um but aidan i think it's learning like
i spent [ __ ] hundreds of hours in
discords watching youtube videos reading
twitter before i said a word yeah
i spent 50 hours on crypto punks before
i moved back in january 50 and i don't
have an out of time
like it's uh for me it's tough because
there's there's so many projects coming
out and it's hard to really vet what
what you know what happened aiden my
hope i didn't buy any top shot i think
it's one of the most important things
that have happened but i understand
sports cards too much and once i saw how
the prices were going i'm like this is
not sustainable you can't make 1300
terry rozier cards highlights and think
it's gonna work out and that's what's
happening overall with nfts right now
oh yeah it's the same type of thing like
when top shot was exploding in like
february and there's getting all the
media attention and stuff like that i
was i was part of that and that's when i
started making my money
but
on the nft side like away from top aydah
let's talk about top chat did you get
left with the bag or did you move enough
or something in between i made a couple
thousand dollars so
but i have i have about like 25 moments
left and took them all off the
marketplace and i'm just comfortable
with holding those
good for you listen i think
my recommendation when people have a
softer bag is to not guess on minting
and wait for something to get a little
traction and then pay a little big
and then really ride that out yeah
you're gonna pay more
but right now people are just guessing
yeah when i meant i'm watching how
they're minting because i have series 2
come out
this is why i keep making this video do
not buy what i'm buying
like you know like
i'm gonna talk about the things i
believe in i don't talk about a lot of
things i don't believe in because i'm
stuck i'm damned if i do damned if i
don't people like you like this is
absurd how people [ __ ] talk to me
they're like gary you can't promote
projects i'm like [ __ ] you i spent my
whole life putting out good content so
that people you didn't earn my audience
i earned my audience all right and if
and if you think i'm gonna go buy a
hundred [ __ ]
like funny frogs or penguins or whatever
the [ __ ] and then so that i could tell
all of you that it's awesome so that i
can then sell it first of all i keep a
public [ __ ] wallet for this reason
my wallet's not hard to find it's the
blockchain
all this [ __ ] i got for sports cards
when i didn't [ __ ] sell anything i'm
like oh i like nfts better here it is
here's my [ __ ] wallet tell me what
i'm doing wrong so
but but you can't follow what i'm buying
i'm buying for different reasons i'm
looking at how they mint i'm looking at
scarcity levels and and i can afford to
spend three thousand dollars on a
lottery ticket yeah most people can't
all right
gary i appreciate it i love all your
videos thank you brother
i really appreciate this this is going
to be
yeah we got this aiden where do you live
i'm in toronto i'm just outside of
toronto
and are you in high school i mean right
high school i took a year off i worked
i'm a barber i cut hair i i saw you want
you want to move to new york and do an
internship with us
i'd love to do something like that i'd
definitely email me for sure uh where
can i find your email it's gary at
vaynermedia okay cool all right thank
you thank you very much you're welcome
very much
let's get one more in
craig
craig
you gotta be kidding me i'm just sitting
here next to aiden on my screen here and
aiden says inside outside of toronto and
i'm outside of toronto right you know
yeah craig i mean and by the way this is
the number one thing i want with be
friends i wanted to build a community
right i look at the star trek
conventions i look at the disney stuff i
look at wrestling con i look at comic
con craig you and aiden have to be
friends like if you're that close oh for
sure for sure like it's like each other
in the chat i mean i see i see tim over
there in the top of my screen too and
alyssa was on here before and we're all
part of the g friends discord and
whatnot like i was in uh in the and of
course in the v friends but also on
clubhouse and let's be friends and
i was there on day one when uh you know
you jumped in there with sal and nicole
and uh
you you just given corso the gift goat
um uh adam there got his uh rabbit you
know he's getting his tattoo with his
rabbit
you said the 47 seconds
like it was insane right like the you
know a lot of people in there know my
story i'm like 53 i did a bit of a reset
used to do outside sales not really what
i wanted i'm taking a six month uh boot
camp i apologize uh
jerseyborn.edu said who knew gary was in
huge it was huge in canada jersey born
not eat we're huge in the [ __ ] world
baby
oh yeah all right keep it exactly no i'm
just saying like guys as in i'm taking a
six month boot camp course on uh full
stack whatever just trying to you know
do a reset and a pivot into that area
you know it's related to stuff i've done
in the past and whatever and uh
you know so my question i guess what i
sort of wrote down here was uh
if um you know how like right now it's
it's like you said it's 47 seconds in i
just been holding on it's 47 seconds in
i'm doing this course it's over in
november
like i can't be on here every minute
whatever if i'm focusing on that it's a
lot of it is a boot camp right and so uh
i'm i'm
i'm not watching every day everything
looking at all these project stuff
whatever like i had to pick my thing i'm
doing this other thing right you know
take care of the family first is the
idea let me get a job that will pay and
there's a potential and
when i get some money that i can play a
bit more with and then there we go right
but like do you think that like right
now obviously there's been some crazy
opportunities and you know but we are
saying it's 47 seconds in
um
but do you think that there's
opportunities that are happening right
now that like just will not happen again
or like in in six months or a year or
two years or three years there's still
going to be opportunities
the answers not not opportunities but
you don't know the opportunity right now
i know exactly what you're answering
you can pay low money now and make a lot
of money whereas there maybe it would be
i got you of course the answer is
in six or 12 months there will not be
the same opportunity of ridiculousness
which is why this is a moment here's the
problem
98 won't be that
yeah so it's it's a big guess it's
lottery yeah
it doesn't this is why i like it i don't
think it's lottery i think it's homework
yes
and intuition and pattern recognition
and a few other things but
it's not lottery i'm not gonna get lucky
i haven't gotten lucky with crypto punks
i didn't get lucky with crypto punks i
didn't i put in the work i looked at
pattern recognition
you know like v friends didn't launch
successfully by accident that was 20
years of work of knowing how to do [ __ ]
i don't think i'm wrong about tom sachs
rockets
and i think
crypto strikers
is an interesting one like i don't think
i'll be wrong if it hits if it fails i
understand and i'll i take those l's all
the time
whereas with chubbies and fame ladies
squad i just like the art and i got
excited i was being like a consumer but
on the things that i those i bought like
10 or 12 but i got excited now i'm
trying to be a little bit less excited
because i'm i didn't realize how
everybody would just follow anything if
we talk even though i say don't buy what
you know everyone's like buying it i
don't want that for you i but for me i i
don't think it's a lottery ticket i
think it's work
yeah
now i know the terrible thing for you is
when you tend to say something it often
is right
so it's not a bad thing but you know
what i mean it is it is risky when you
know a lot of people are listening and
and they can do stuff with maybe with
money like you said that they can't you
know so
it's tricky whatever but i gotta say
that like the whole concept aside from
you know all this stuff and whatever
else but your whole concept around the v
friends characteristics and traits and
whatnot
is gold like it i believe that like
wholeheartedly like i align with that
and relate to that like so much
and the community that's been built you
know from that
is gold
not just for me but for almost everybody
that's in here i hear it all the time in
the in the different clubs and places
that i'm in
and you know we just really really
appreciate uh what you're doing and the
fact that like it's not lost on me that
like even here i jump in a zoom column
500 people away from garyvee i've
watched you know garrett t with garyvee
a few times people saying like you know
i've been following you for 10 years and
it took me that long to get with you you
know what i mean and the
the closeness and the amount of caring
that you can see that you you give us
in the discord and in in forums like
this is insane and unheard of
in the world that you travel
you know what i mean it just isn't it
this doesn't happen of course of course
it's why we're not going to be it's why
we're going to be a different community
yes
i i always laugh i know i'm underrated
we haven't even started
we're doing different things because
we're different
exactly i made enough money for my life
to be happy when i made a hundred
thousand dollars a year that happened a
long time ago yeah on a completely
different course with completely
different ambitions
and
when people look at what happens with
beef like do you know how much joy i get
that people sitting here that do have 10
eth and they're buying four stupid
projects and the friends are sitting
there at 70 it makes me happy i like it
i like being underestimated even by my
biggest fans
yeah
that's awesome so i appreciate it you
know like there's been a number of times
in the discord and different things
where you know there could have been
opportunity to have a chat with you and
the chance to i'm glad that out of 500 i
got this chance that's just the goal
makes me i appreciate
team i'm going to jump back into discord
i got to go do some family stuff i had
this window i wanted to give back some
love a couple things
don't be scared to take some profits off
the board with your second third fourth
and fifth favorite projects you're in
whether it's v friends or something else
don't you don't have to do that with
your first one
but don't be scared too with your second
third fourth and fifth i am incredibly
concerned by how many projects are
coming out every day
i think this is
going to be very hard to sustain what
we're seeing right now so if you're day
trading nfts be thoughtful what you're
playing with be very thoughtful because
when it turns it turns that it's done
people always think they can catch the
market you cannot catch the market
far smarter people than you and i did
not catch the market every time the
market collapsed in real estate the
stock market beanie babies sports cards
sneakers like
be thoughtful be [ __ ] smart um and
and
put in real homework don't buy [ __ ] just
because i bought it or somebody else
that you think is doing well bought it
like do your homework spend time in the
discords make relationships and never
give out your secret seed phrase nobody
will ever ask for it it will never
happen nobody not metamask not coinbase
not open scene not me
um we're still in the early wild wild
west stage and people are
getting their stuff stolen which is
unfortunate i want to use this moment
again
to remind you this is what comes the
beautiful thing about the blockchain is
nobody's in charge
the bad thing is nobody's in charge
when when people get their b friends
stolen and they hit me up and they're
like i can't do [ __ ] about it
i can put public pressure but these are
hidden what like so be thoughtful this
is a this is a special time that's why
it's amazing and scary it's special it's
different that's what it's supposed to
be so do your homework and um and i'll
see you in the defense discord in a few
minutes we can chat a little bit love
you have a great great weekend great
rest of the weekend bye
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you